[Applause]
thousand hearts before I met you and I'm
done I'll break a thousand more baby
before I am through
Ken John walks offset after Rudy
Giuliani is revealed as one of the
disguised contestants on The Masked
Singer I can either confirm nor deny
that but yes so what led to the
surprising moment Wednesday's episode
introduced the final five contestants
frog prince Queen Cobra space bunny baby
mammoth and Jack in the Box
[Applause]
following all their performances the
audience voted for their favor and in
the end it was Jack in the Box who got
the boot which left the panel of Judges
Robin Thicke Jenny McCarthy Nicole
Scherzinger and Ken to make their final
guesses
Joe Pesci I'm thinking it might be
Robert Duvall you know what I am
sticking with Elon Musk
however no one came close to Jack in the
Box's real identity
oh my goodness former associate Attorney
General
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey no
way yeah the former New York City
mayor's reveal caused mixed reactions
from the judges and left the usually
funny Ken not so happy
[Applause]
before I met you and I'm done I'll break
a thousand more baby before I am through
I've had multiple times where I was
surprised but based on Ken's reaction
this surprise feels different than
others before
ET has reached out to the comedian and
The Masked Singer for comment of course
fans knew this was coming back in
February when the show is filming news
first broke of the community star
exiting the stage in protest after
giuliani's unmasking and since then
neither the panel nor the show have
publicly commented on it but it sure got
the internet talking like political
pundit and frequent guest host on The
View Anna Navarro who shared her two
cents on Twitter writing quote I thought
there could not ever possibly be worse
and more humiliating footage of Rudy
Giuliani than when she covered sweaty
dye streaked down his face I was wrong
another fan writes my heart goes out to
Ken Jong I know how you feel this show
should have never cast Rudy Giuliani
this is supposed to be a positive show
not a negative show but they were also
the those who showed their support for
the former mayor with one user tweeting
Ken Jong has a terrible sense of humor I
stand with Rudy Giuliani now there may
be mixed emotions about the whole thing
but in the end Giuliani shared his
personal reason for deciding to do the
show I just had a granddaughter Grace
and I want her to know that you should
try everything even things that are
completely unlike you and unlikely and I
couldn't think of anything more unlike
me and unlikely than this we get to the
heart and the core of these these things
with the stories of these contestants
and we realize at the end of the day
we're all a lot more alike and the same
than we realize and we all go through
the same struggles and it's just it's
it's beautiful we got a little bit of
everything a hodgepodge of everything
and that's why we're so great guys
that's what we're big time
[Music]
thank you